data fication refers to the fact that
we're looking at more aspects of life
that we never actually understood as
being informational before and finding
out that in fact there is an
informational quality to it that we can
render into a data format so what we're
seeing with social media companies is
they're actually data fiying aspects of
the life that we never really saw that
could be data fide so for example
Facebook data fires our friendships
Twitter data flies our whispers or maybe
our stray thoughts and LinkedIn data
files our professional contacts and more
and more and more are we seeing that
we're able to take the daily
interactions of living things that we
never really saw that could be rendered
into a data format and we're putting it
into data formats now what does this
mean in the big picture the factors were
just at the outset of the big data era
so we're gonna find out but you can just
use your imagination and think of some
of the extraordinary uses one way that
we're doing it is looking at who
contacts whom on Twitter and whose ones
followers are and we're able to identify
that and we've never known this before
that subpopulations exist that are
either a minyan eyes for the flu or are
not now it's a public health issue the
whole point of vaccinations is that you
take a broad population you vaccinate
many but not all and everyone is covered
what we've just now learned with Twitter
is that this idea of herd immunity might
not be the case because there's whole
subgroups of the population that all
don't get vaccinated yet they all hang
out together they do virtually and we're
seeing that those virtual ties are also
physical ties I want to stress this
sounds like it might be a intuitive
thing it's not it sounds like this might
just be a nice thing to know it's deadly
important it's very serious and it took
data fiying relationships and
interactions to learn it so when you
think about it in the grand scheme what
Big Data means is we are able to learn
things about ourselves at the population
level at a huge scale that we never
could in the past so lots of different
disciplines in one case
sociology totally gets upended because
in the past you ran small studies on
small groups now you're looking at it in
a population scale size